je vais donc
vous lire une déclaration de
l'intersyndicale et puis ensuite vous
pourrez discuter évidemment avec chacun
d'entre nous
donc soutenu par des millions de
travailleurs et travailleurs mobilisés
depuis bientôt trois mois dans toute la
France pour le retrait de la réforme des
retraites nos 8 organisations syndicales
ont été reçues ce jour par la première
ministre
à cette occasion nous lui avons une fois
de plus redit combien sa réforme est
aussi injuste que brutal
injuste parce qu'elle aggrave les
inégalités déjà présentes dans le
système actuel
brutal parce qu'aucune urgence pas même
comptable ne justifiait d'aller ainsi au
pas de course et d'escamoter la
consultation des partenaires sociaux
à aucun moment nos propositions
alternatives de financement n'ont été
prises au sérieux quant au processus
parlementaire on sait à quelle vie se
démocratique a conduit le refus de le
mener à son terme
à la crise sociale s'ajoute aujourd'hui
la crise démocratique nos concitoyens
qui ont très largement et très
pacifiquement exprimé leur opposition à
cette réforme ne comprendrez pas que
leur mobilisation et à travers elle leur
parole soit ignorées nous avons donc
redit à la première ministre qui ne
saurait y avoir d'autres issus
démocratiques que le retrait du texte
la première ministre a répondu qu'elle
souhaitait maintenir son texte une
décision grave cette réforme est refusée
par la quasi-totalité de la population
il faut la retirer nous refusons de
tourner la page et d'ouvrir comme le
souhaite le gouvernement d'autres
séquences de concertation sur des
dossiers aussi divers que le plein
emploi ou le partage des richesses
chacune de nos organisations sur chacun
des dossiers suggérés pour un formuler
le moment venu des propositions de
nature à améliorer l'existence de nos
concitoyens mais le moment n'est pas
venu la vie des travailleurs et des
travailleurs que nous représentons et
que nous défendons n'est pas réductible
à un enchaînement de séquences le report
à 64 ans de l'âge légal à des de départ
en retraite aura sur la vie de nos
concitoyens sur leur santé sur leurs
projets des conséquences très concrètes
c'est pourquoi nous nous retournerons
pas à la table des concertations comme
si de rien n'était et appelons une fois
encore au retrait pur et simple de ce
texte nous en appelons à la sagesse du
Conseil constitutionnel qui doit
entendre la juste colère des
travailleuses et des travailleurs enfin
nous appelons ces derniers à se joindre
massivement aux nombreux cortèges qui
défileront demain à Paris dans toute la
France pour dire une onzième fois non à
cette réforme injuste et brutale
merci
c'est forcément un échec quand la
Première ministre ne fait aucune
ouverture sur cette discussion donc